when you look around the world the
deteriorating economy could cause
massive problems in terms of state
failure throughout parts of Africa I
also worry about the absence of economic
growth what it would mean for countries
say like like China and its potential
stability and I think also there the
lack of trade the fact of trade is now
contracting around the world rather than
growing has I think unfortunate not just
economic consequences but but political
consequences deal the only upside I can
see on the economic side funnily enough
is the fact that some of the energy
dependent economies but you're
essentially cash crop economies like
Iran and Venezuela to some extent Russia
aren't going to have that luxury of
enormous Treasuries and as a result in
the case of Russia they may actually
have to develop a real economy which
wouldn't be bad news and in the case of
places like Iran or Venezuela they won't
have this all these extra resources to
cause mischief and indeed to the
contrary they may have to be more
responsible to their own citizens for
the delivery of essential services and a
standard of living but by and large
those are the exceptions and I think the
struggling world economy will you'll see
the the growth of friction within in
between states because of it and it's
not an immediate crisis but over time it
could be a real drag if you will on on
global stability